m
[Musique]
paris demeure ou changent selon les
quartiers
il change mal les bétons l'an les bcae
le banalise certains quartiers en
revanche les is bien pour la joie des
artistes toujours présents et les
touristes toujours plus nombreux
il reste un art de vivre à dimension
humaine
discrètement des mots des parisiens pas
cosmopolite la santé du roi louis 9 de
france est contestée par quelques-uns
pourtant ce o'neal damparis o'neal tout
entière reste un monument liées à son
nom elle est une île sur la scène mais
aussi sur le cours du temps son visage
ses membres ses habits n'ont guère
changé depuis 300 ans l'île saint louis
c'est un cadeau que le passé fait à
paris et à ses visiteurs un urbaniste de
goût a dessiné l'île saint louis avec
une grande rigueur
c'est unique rue principale couper
régulièrement angle droit par des ruses
affluentes la rue saint louis en l'île
détermine un tracé harmonieux une
distribution heureuse des volumes
construit
l'hôtel chemise au bâti vers 16 centres
amp préfigure certains modèles de
l'aristocratie îlienne noble alors grand
bourgeois aujourd'hui qu'un ménage avec
art parfois avec goût les appartements
splendide mais secret autour de l'île
saint-louis vis à vis populaire animé
pas très doré bizarrement les riches
demeures disparaissent dans l'harmonie
générale des habitations modestes quand
il est vrai que la forêt cachent les
arbres celui qui est né à paris disait
alexandre dumas à une rue pour pays
natal dans l'île saint louis les vieux
peuvent encore regarder autour d'eux
sans décevoir leurs souvenirs d'enfant
aujourd'hui le numéro 1 de la rue
principale est devenu un temple du goût
je veux dire de la dégustation insulaire
locaux habitants de continents plus
éloignés et même du lointain paris
viennent ici attendre avec patience un
plaisir céleste une glace bertillon le
miss était gratuite mérité par la
qualité de l'artisan les secrets
appartement de l'île cachent leur siège
signé jacob et leur commode griffé bull
le célèbre glacier donne son nom à des
merveilles aussi périssables que
m'aimera messieurs persillon comment
avez vous commencé ici incidemment c'est
à dire que en 1954
j'ai repris la succession de mes beaux
parents en tant que cafés hôtels et
comme j'avais récupéré à d'aumône ancien
métier de boulanger-pâtissier 2 petit
appareil à fabriquer la glace je me suis
lancé dans la fabrication tout à fait
réduite de sorbet et de crème glacée et
puis on court des années ma production
s'est développée et
nous sommes agrandis maintenant nous
sommes presque arrivés à notre maximum
est ce qu'un peu plus repousser les murs
mais ça marche assez bien maison l'île
saint louis s'est d'abord appelée il
notre dame car elle appartenait à la
paroisse de la cathédrale voisine au
xviiie siècle l'église dédiée à saint
louis décida du nom définitif de ce lieu
de proportions modestes cette église se
reconnaît de loin à son clocher
l'horloge s'en détache comme une
enseigne
elles ne présentent aucun intérêt
architectural particulier et fut
construite à l'alignement des immeubles
pour éviter aux habitants de devoir
quitter leur île pour aller à l'église
sur d'autres rives
les autorités ecclésiastiques de notre
dame ont longtemps refusé à l'île saint
louis
l'autorisation de construire des ponts
il s'agissait de protéger ainsi l'île de
la cité des crues et des inondations
redoutable qui l'a ravagée
c'est ici que vit georges moustaki
louisiens depuis plus de vingt ans déjà
paris pour lui c'est l'île saint louis
il ya longtemps que l'on zigzag l émoi
travers paris
tout doucement sans faire de 20 du
point-du-jour al issaoui il ya longtemps
davantage qu'elles écoutent mes rêveries
qu'elle me renvoie mon image
quand je ne sais plus qui je suis
je regarde pas cela seul le pont marie
[Musique]
je regarde
passer la st
quatre quais entourent l'île saint-louis
mariant la pierre avec l'eau la lumière
joue sur le fleuve et les berges
s'éparpillent dans le feuillage des
grands peupliers charme discret des
lieux habités avec joie où l'on vit sans
à seul y sont affairés les chiens qui
s'en vont seuls et les touristes dont
les troupeaux arrête pour un moment
quelques fébrile migration et d'anjou
qe2 bourbeau and ses décors ou le passé
de paris re a sur son avenir
pierre vittu journaliste écrivain habite
précisément qu'est bourbeau j'ai vu
considérablement changé les saint-louis
en toute une vie je les ai vus parce que
je suis né dans l'île saint louis je
suis né dans l'appartement que j'habite
toujours et en remontant dans mes
souvenirs d'enfance
je garde le souvenir d'un quartier de
paris un peu exceptionnel c'était une
petite province dans la grande ville
plutôt un petit village à ce moment là
les st louis était surtout habitée par
des artisans par des gens simples et par
quelques par quelques artistes et hommes
de lettres qui avaient été séduits par
le calme de ces quais très ombragé car
il y avait deux magnifiques peupliers
qui peignait leurs pieds dans l'eau
donnait une autre sur tout le pourtour
de l'île ont été vos lisa coupé pour les
arts planté mais il me semble que
l'ombre de ces peupliers de mon enfance
était encore plus fourni plus dense et
plus agréable qu'aujourd'hui
[Musique]
lille n'a jamais été menacé d'être
pétrifié en musée ses habitants n'ont
pas quitté pour en faire une réserve à
touristes la préserver sa personnalité
vivent presque par elle-même sur m
la rue centrale définit l'espace
intérieur de l'île saint louis
elle traverse le monde insulaire du
levant au ponant comme tracé à la règle
sans détours artère qui bat
l'ouest et l'est de l'île l'ifer entre
l'est montre une réserve toute
aristocratique l'ouest au contraire
c'est le ventre de livres le ventre de
paris les halles et et hier encore tout
proche
elles ont essaimé ici commerces et
boutiques
dans ses magasins d'alimentation se
révèle la vitalité de ce quartier sa
bonne santé
cette tradition aussi commerce de détail
dialogue sur la qualité des produits
pas de protéines pré conditionné choisir
un fromage reste comme il se doit
une cérémonie il y encore des vendeuses
qui éprouvent sur leurs poitrines la
consistance du camembert et sa maturité
sa douceur sous les doigts c'est au
toucher que se révèle la qualité de
leurs fromages de leur poitrine aussi
accessoirement le célèbre bien manger
français disparus ailleurs célèbre
encore ces rites dans ce lieu préservé
paris et pour des millions d'individus
la patrie de leur choix des immigrés du
monde entier y ont trouvé refuge
on ne peut imaginer l'île saint louis
sans ses immigrés polonais ils sont
arrivés après l'échec du soulèvement
contre les russes en 1831 et pour fuir
les allemands quand la guerre a commencé
ils sont restés là
l'île de la cité est une poupe du
vaisseau l'île saint louis une pro le
pont marie reste le lien le plus ancien
une reliée à la terre ferme le petit il
dédié à saint louis aux yeux de membres
de louisiens lille pourrait très bien
subsister sans communication avec paris
le rêve de quelques privilégiés et d'y
vivre dans un isolement de bon ton
quelques snob nouveaux venus ils sont
apparus le snobisme un effet la
prétention à n'en faire un des lieux les
plus chères de france
[Musique]
pourtant on y trouve encore par tout le
petit monde intacte des angles j'habite
en d'hyères un monde toujours éclatante
santé au pain de sucre une vitrine
décorée de collier de sucre candy et de
toutes sortes de sucre de couleurs
variées tendre et chatoyant blanche
on n'en finit pas d'être séduit par
l'enchantement discret de ses
perspectives l'île saint-louis ses
caisses et recoins certaine qualité de
silence certains mystères aussi dans
l'évidence ce mairie balzac comparer
l'île saint-louis à venise venise peut
en être fier pourtant les roues et les
machines du progrès cern ce lieu en
menacent les privilèges
yay amoureux de lille georges moustaki
s'inquiètent de l'avenir
chose qui a changé c'est peut-être un
détail mais c'était très important il ya
quelques années il y avait un restaurant
où tout le monde allait c'était pas cher
du tout c'était très bon là la patronne
la serveuse étaient des personnages très
populaire parmi les gens de l'île et
tout le monde se réunissait en voyez
bien on rit aussi bien des maçons des
artistes des ministres ou d'hommes
d'affaires
il y avait donc un moment de la journée
où toutes les salles oui enfin une
erreur de représentation des individus
qui vivent à l'île saint louis se
rencontrer pour manger il paraît se
passer par les canaux failli se
connaissaient ce genre de restaurant est
devenue maintenant des restaurants plus
touristiques et personne n'y va ça fait
que les gens de l'île saint-louis reste
restent chez eux bien vont dans des
cafés en dehors à part la brasserie de
saint louis qui est au fond et qui reste
un lieu nocturne surtout qui fait le
même usage mais on peut encore se
rencontrer
il n'y a pas de lieu où les gens sont
contents bavarder pour jouer aux échecs
pour boire un verre ensemble et ça ça
beaucoup séparer les gens se les est
cloisonné chacun trouvé son petit
univers et il n'y a plus ces rencontres
chose qui manque beaucoup c'est qu'on ne
dira jamais assez l'importance
sociologique des bistrots et de
l'importance je pense d'ailleurs c'est
une chose qui m'a frappé quand j'étais à
berlin c'est la profusion de café et des
cas fiction très belle envie de
s'asseoir aux novices sur l'appui du
d'après de changer parce qu'on a envie
d'être pas ils savent où il y avait des
endroits comme ça où il y avait un
climat de rencontre et ce climat
n'existe plus
[Musique]
l'île saint-louis trouvera les remède à
ses maux de croissance
elle restera l'un des charmes de cette
capitale de cette capitale dans
hemingway a dit si tu avais le bonheur
de vivre jeune homme à paris qui
comporterait la ville en toi pour le
reste de ses jours
partout où tu irais ensuite car paris
est une fête pour la vie
[Musique]